a plane carrying 107 people has crashed
in Pakistan in a residential area of the
country's largest city Karachi according
to the Civil Aviation Authority the
Pakistan International Airlines flight
from Lahore was about to land at Karachi
Airport when it crashed well our
correspondent ash the hurry nag is
following the story and she has more ash
neck Allen yes as you say we have heard
in the last few minutes that the
Pakistan Civil Aviation Authority have
confirmed that this sadly and this
aircraft has crashed in the nearby city
and near this Airport
we believe that 91 passengers were on
board with seven members of crew it's
believed that this was a Pakistan
International Airlines flight it was an
airbus a320 which had taken off from
lahore and it was due to land at the
Jinnah International Airport in Karachi
when it crashed in as you can see a
residential populated area these the
latest pictures that were bringing you
now
as you can see hugely congested area
very busy this of course around this
time of year it's Ramadan for many
Muslims in Pakistan all across the world
and ambulance they're coming in to just
chaotic scene many people will be
wondering what on earth has happened who
is on board where are these people's
families and obviously this flight is it
was due to land at about 3 o'clock we
understand that it crashed about 2:45
local time and from you from what you
can see on these images quite a built-up
area pictures of huge clouds of smoke
and flames earlier on some pictures I
saw flames rising into the sky these
very recent pictures and can show that
very heavily congested many people quite
confused we know there are ambulance on
the scene and police too as well lots of
people gathering around trying to help
and at this stage we are unsure of how
many casualties there are but I think
it's safe to assume that many of those
passengers will it being Eid of course
on Saturday many of those people no
doubt flying home to celebrate with
their families some incredibly tragic
had an incident